welcome to 3abn today Bible q a my name
is Angela Loma King I'm glad that you've
tuned in today yo you are going to be
blessed there's a saying that says
nothing less than a whole Bible can make
a whole Christian and boy is that true
amen I want the Lord wants you to study
his word
study it daily not just once in a while
but study it every day and pray for the
Holy Spirit to lead you and guide you as
you read his word
well today we will be answering your
questions thank you for allowing us to
go to God's word for the answers and we
have a wonderful panelist but before I
go on if you have questions that you
would like to send in to us you can send
email the questions by going to Q Bible
QA at
3abn.tv imma say it again Bible QA at
3abn dot TV and you can also text your
questions into us and it is at
618-228-3975
618-228-3975 and you can also Instagram
if you go to Instagram you can go to at
3abn
underscore official so there are several
ways you can send your questions in
well we have a wonderful panel here
today and I would like to introduce to
you Shelly Quinn Shelly welcome oh it's
a joy to be here we want to thank
everybody for sending in their questions
it's just it's fun for us to get in and
address these questions and Shelly you
have a new book that you have just
written don't you yes I do it'll be
coming out in a few months what's the
name of it spotless experiencing the
Everlasting Covenant through
righteousness by faith oh beautiful I'm
looking forward to reading that thank
you okay next to you we have Daniel
Perrin welcome Daniel thank you happy to
be here and you work in the Pastoral
Department I do so I get to prepare for
Bible questions and answers here but
sometimes I get them right on the spot
on the phone and I gotta gotta give an
answer right there yeah yeah give an
answer for the hope that is within you
is right all right right in front of me
is my darling husband Pastor John
welcome I love the that darling my
darling wife right in front of me good
to have you here honey
thank you glad to have you here that's
right we got a chance to share a Bible
on television and study Bible at home
together what a blessed joy and the more
we do that the more we find out how deep
God's river is and we're going to look
forward to that we we're deep sea diving
today
amen would you open with a word of
prayer sure loving father in Heaven
thank you for your word it is an
inexhaustible book and our minds are so
finite that sometimes
what we try to retain we don't remember
but we thank you that the promise is
what have you we have learned your holy
spirit will bring it back to our
remembrance do so now Lord as we respond
to the questions that have been given to
us may you be glorified in the answers
we pray in Jesus name amen amen a
Seventh-Day Adventist Christians we have
always been known to be people of the
book and the book is the word of God so
I must start this question I'm going to
ask Shelley Quinn this question
okay here it goes it's uh oh it's an
interesting question it says I
understand that ham committed sexual
immorality by having sex with his father
while his father was drunk
but I have encountered other Christians
who believe that Ham's sin was just to
see the nakedness of his father no
sexual intercourse
please help us clarify
the matter was Ham's what what was Ham's
sin
the idea that ham had sex with his
father Noah is twisting the scriptures
to your own destruction as second Peter
3 16 says let me prove it to you the
story is found in Genesis 9 20-27.
Noah had three sons ham Shem and japheth
and it this story shows that God knew in
advance how each one of them would
exercise their Free Will and it the
story lays bare the the failure of
righteous Noah after he exited the ark
he planted a Vineyard he drank of the
wine he got drunk and lay in his uh tent
naked so his son Ham and most likely
very plausibly you'll see why Ham's son
Kanan which would have been Noah's
grandson
saw lying naked in his tent they gawked
at him and they mocked him they went and
told
Jim and japheth about their father's sin
so Shem and japheth
refused to participate in this mocking
they were following God's moral code of
love that you should honor your father
and your mother so what they did is they
put a blanket on them they walked in
backwards and they covered without
looking at Noah they covered his
nakedness so here's what happens when
Noah awoke he spoke prophetically and he
was Guided by God God knows the end from
the beginning
so Noah curse now get this he didn't
curse ham interesting he cursed Kanan oh
and that shows you it wasn't him having
sex with his father but he cursed Canaan
strongly implying that this grandson
with it was either complicit or
instigated the event in the beginning
and Noah prophesied that Kanan would be
the servant of Shem so we see that Ham's
descendants became the cushites the
Egyptians and the Canaanites and Ham
never I mean these people what they did
they never followed the one true God
they invented Idols they in they
instituted the Pagan religion basically
so in reality ham ended up worshiping
demons rather than worshiping God there
is nothing in scripture nothing
absolutely nothing that suggests ham had
sex with his father that is a twisted
teaching I wonder where they got that
from I don't know yes nowhere in the
Bible is the first I've ever heard a
question like this so wow thank you
Shelly and I failed to mention that we
have three each question is answered
within three minutes and we also have
one four minute question so I'm gonna
start with the four minute question
to Daniel okay Daniel here we go
and this is a simple question what's the
role of the holy spirit this is from
dawn in New York okay all right a short
question and also a simple question when
we just read the Bible there's well over
200 Bible texts that refer to the holy
spirit so there is plenty uh plenty of
room for you to continue studying on
this topic the holy spirit is simply the
personal being of the godhead who
administers the presence and the power
of God to you and to to me so let me
give you I got quite a few texts to
share here really quickly the Holy
Spirit dwells within you first
Corinthians 6 9 which means the work of
the Holy Spirit comes inside you have
control over whether or not to give the
Holy Spirit permission but to the holy
spirit's work is internal the Holy
Spirit inspires scripture all right a
second Peter 1 21 Men of God spoke as
they were moved by the Holy Spirit and
the Holy Spirit communicates God law and
his instruction to us Exodus 35 31
bezalel was filled with the spirit of
God in wisdom and understanding First
Chronicles 28 12. David gave Solomon the
plans for this the sanctuary the temple
that the Holy Spirit had put in his mind
and then the Holy Spirit who inspires
the scriptures and teaches us helps us
to understand the scriptures John 15 26
says that the holy spirits will testify
holy spirit will testify of me that's of
Jesus in John 14 26 the helper the Holy
Spirit whom the father will send in my
name will teach you all things and will
bring to remembrance the things that I
have said John 16 verse 13 says that the
holy spirit will guide you into all
truth and will tell you what is to come
just a few verses earlier in verse 8 of
chapter 16 the Holy Spirit Will convict
the world of guilt in regard to sin and
righteousness and judgment so the holy
spirit is prompting your thoughts giving
you thoughts to think which you can
choose to accept or reject well if you
accept the thoughts that the Holy Spirit
prompts in your mind then you receive
more and you become settled into the
truth more and more so Ephesians 1
verses 13 and 14 says you were sealed
with the Holy Spirit of promise this is
you continuing to be filled more and
more with God's thinking and so the Holy
Spirit then it says is your guarantee
the guarantee of our inheritance by
prompting your thoughts the holy spirit
is also prompting your actions and
notice I said prompting not forcing the
Holy Spirit doesn't take over you and
take control of your body Genesis 6
verse 3 says and the Lord said my spirit
shall not strive with Man Forever This
is the act of persuading and convincing
and appealing Ezekiel 36 verse 27 says I
will put my spirit within you and cause
you to walk in my statutes and you will
keep my judgments and do them the holy
spirit's work is to lead you to
obedience the evidence of the holy
spirit is not emotional outbursts it's
not energetic expressions or experiences
and it's not even necessarily good good
music the evidence of the holy spirit's
work is obedience to what God asks
that's always the evidence and so that
evidence then produces in US
sanctification all by the Holy Spirit
listen to Second Thessalonians 2 13. God
from the beginning shows you for
salvation through sanctification by the
spirit Titus 3 verse 5 says he saved us
through the washing of regeneration and
renewing of the Holy Spirit the holy
spirit's work in US begins to change us
and fashion us into having the lives
that God has now this could go on and on
and give you one more text here and then
one final one you shall receive power
when the Holy Spirit comes on you this
is acts 1 1 verse 8 and you shall be
witnessed is to me so the holy spirit's
work in your life then gives you the
ability to utter and to speak and to
share the word of God and finally one
more Romans 8 verse 11 if the spirit of
him who raised Jesus from the dead
dwells in you he who raised Christ from
the dead will give life also to your
mortal bodies through the spirit who
dwells in you looking off into the
future the holy spirit's power from
start to finish is the one that works
out God's plan in your life amen amen
can you grieve the Holy Spirit
you can people can grieve the Holy
Spirit Ephesians 4 30 it talks about
grieving the Holy Spirit you don't want
to do that he's working with all of us
isn't he amen thank you for that okay
pastor John you have a four minute
question yes okay this is from Crystal
she sent an email in
I was baptized at the age of 12 but left
the church when I was 16. I feel God is
calling me back to the church but I
struggle with fornication
can you explain Hebrews verse 26 the
Holy Spirit led me to scriptures about
fornication but my flesh still yearns
for it even though I know it's wrong
are there sins that God won't forgive
once we have knowledge of them and still
do them and this is from Christian you
have to explain fornication because
someone out there may not know what it
is go ahead well they made it clear in
the um in the scripture says my this the
Holy Spirit Led me in the scriptures
about fornication but their flesh still
yearns for this this is the lust of the
flesh uh lust of the flesh specifically
in a in a sexual Manner and this is
something that the world the world this
generation more than any other has been
so proactive and pushing uh in music and
movies and and advertisement this is
what I refer to as the most corrupt
generation that I've ever experienced
and it's becoming more and more corrupt
as the day goes on but this passage that
you read in Hebrews 10 26 and let me go
ahead and read that for you and then
we'll break it down to three categories
and five quick answers one Hebrews 10 26
says for if we willfully sin after we
have received the knowledge of the truth
there no longer remains a sacrifice for
sins the inference here is you led into
this a moment ago Ephesians 4 30 this is
talking about iniquity the unpardonable
sin a heart that says I know what the
Lord says but I'm not giving this one up
and we're told in Hebrews let us lay
aside every weight in the Sin that's so
easily ensnares or besets us some people
want to be Christians but they're not
getting rid of their darling sins as
Pastor Brooks used to call them the
darling sins the one that they love so
much the one that causes them to so
easily be beset so if you by the way for
asking this question means you haven't
reached that point yet now let me just
bring out three very quick things first
your temptation is not unique First
Corinthians 10 13 no temptation has
overtaken you but such as his common
demand but God is faithful who will not
allow to be tempted beyond what you are
able but with the Temptation make a way
of Escape that you may be able to Bear
it your temptation is not unique but God
still has a way to escape secondly your
struggle is not unique the Bible says
Paul talked about this he says uh for
what I'm doing in Romans 7 15 I do not
understand for what I will to do that I
do not practice but what I hate that I
do the difference here is
Paul wasn't lustfully yearning for
fornication yearning after a sexual sin
whatever Paul's struggle was he says I
just can't find the human effort to be
able to overcome this thing that is so
strong against me but God gave him the
victory as he can also do for you and
then finally your request is not unique
Romans 7 24 Paul asked the question
you're asking o Wretched Man that I am
who will deliver me from the body of
this death so let me make the answers
very quickly first one do not expose
yourself to situations where you will
fall don't expose yourself Romans 13
verse 14 but put on the Lord Jesus
Christ and make no provision for the
flesh to fulfill it Celeste you know
when you are approaching a situation
where you have no power to resist it
don't allow yourself to move in that
direction resist by the power of Christ
I can do all things through Christ who
strengthens me secondly don't yield to
Temptation if you do you will fall the
Bible says in Romans 6 16 do you not
know that to whom you present yourself
slaves to obey you are that one slave
whom you obey whether of sin leading to
death or obedience leading to
righteousness if you allow the flesh to
lead it'll be sin leading to death if
you allow the spirit of God to lead
it'll be obedience leading to
righteousness third one make a choice
and not allow sin to take the upper hand
Romans 6 verse 12 and 13 therefore do
not let sin reign in your mortal body
that you should obey it in its lust and
do not present your members as
instruments of unrighteousness to sin
but present yourself to God as being
alive from the dead and your members as
instruments of righteousness take a
sanctifying stand about what you can do
with your body say this is God's Temple
I'm not going to throw myself around in
a loose way because God does not desire
for his body to be polluted and finally
when Temptation comes call on the Lord
Romans 10 13 for whoever calls on the
name of the Lord shall be saved that's a
promise and that is a guarantee
amen and the Lord will make a way of
Escape he always does the very first one
that you may be able to Bear it he'll
not allow a temptation to come
as a one person says God measures every
trial every temptation but he doesn't
measure his grace and his Mercy amen
unto him that is able right able to keep
you from Pauling thank you honey 24. yes
thank you well said
hey Shelly
oh this is your four-minute question
wow this is straight to the point this
is from Elisha in Ghana
how can I stop sinning wow
that's wonderful at least the way we
stop sinning is to enter into a covenant
relationship with the Lord and allow him
to do his will in us God has an
Everlasting Covenant of righteousness by
faith it was introduced in the garden
and it's always been his plan to save us
there are two aspects to righteousness
by faith the imputed righteousness of
Christ occurs that means it's credited
to us it occurs when we accept Christ as
our savior and his record of complete
Conformity to God's will is credited to
our account this is what we call
justification to be justified means that
God looks at you he no longer sees any
evidence any forensic evidence evidence
of your sin he declares you not guilty
he delivers you from the penalty of sin
that is an act of God but there is also
the second aspect which is a work of God
I call it
infused righteousness this occurs when
as you said in Ephesians 3 16-20 talks
about the Holy Spirit indwelling
Christians Christ lives in our heart by
faith when he is in us and the spirit
empowers us to do God's will separating
us from sin that's all this is called
sanctification sanctification merely
means to be separated from sin he
delivers us from the power of sin so
this is a work of God it is a lifelong
process so let me give you three steps
Elisha that God gave me
and I believe this is how we best enter
into Covenant relationship with him step
one
know God and His will you've got to
study his word you've got to know his
love what he feels for you you've got to
trust he has Superior knowledge and
Trust his power to save you salvation
belongs to him step two
stop resisting his love and submit
you've got to receive his love and
forgiveness and submit to his authority
you know Jesus said in John 14 15-17 he
said if you love me keep my Commandments
and I will give you another helper the
Holy Spirit you are talking about and we
can't quit sinning by our own power it
has to be through the Holy Spirit but
James 4 7 and 8 on this idea of
submission that means to line up under
God's will it's actually a military term
he says submit to God
oh Lord I'm willing to be made willing
to do your will submit to God resist the
devil and he will flee from you draw
near to God and He will draw near to you
cleanse your hands you Sinners purify
your hearts you double-minded step three
yield to the leading of the holy spirit
in Luke 11 verses 9 and 10 Jesus said
ask and keep on asking seek and keep on
seeking knock and keep on knocking then
Luke 11 13 explains what he's talking
about he says if you being evil know how
to give good gifts to your children how
much more will the heavenly father give
the Holy Spirit to those who ask and
keep on asking and here's the key Romans
8 13 and 14. it says if you live
according to the flesh you're going to
die you're going to experience that
second death but if by the spirit you
put to death the Deeds of the body as
you said Daniel the Holy Spirit never
forces us we can't do it by ourself but
if by the spirit's power you put to
death the Deeds of the body you will
live for as many as are led by the
spirit of God these are the sons of God
so you've got to count on his power to
separate you from sin to sanctify you
and count on his promise from
Philippians 2 13 that says that he will
work in you to Will and to do his good
pleasure and Philippians 1 6 that he
will complete the good work he has begun
in you it's by God's power that you can
quit sinning and Die daily huh every day
give it to the Lord and I like what you
said willing to be made willing amen I
love that thank you Shelly okay Daniel
are you ready for this I'm ready okay
this is from Linda in Wyoming
if sin no sorry is that the one yes if
sin can't exist in the presence of God
the Father
how did Satan survive when he was going
about heaven lying and sinning against
God
how does he survive at the savior's
return when all other unrepentant
Sinners don't
okay
parenting teaches me a lot of lessons
and they apply to my spiritual life why
doesn't a parent disown a child and kick
them out of the house from the first
moment Rebellion begins in the child's
heart the reason is is because we don't
want our children out we want them back
we want them to understand and accept
the principles of authority and right
and wrong and children don't respond
well to do this because I said so or
else I'm going to kick you out they need
to see and this is the principle that is
at work in the way that God deals with
sin so the anointed cherub that we are
that we see in Ezekiel 28 15. it says
you were perfect in your ways from the
day you were created till iniquity was
found in you so why didn't God just
destroy Lucifer right then and there
in his sin he had challenged the
authority of God and the spiritual
battle must be played out so people
could see and make a choice so Angels
could see and make a choice
uh continuing in a little bit of a
different direction God's presence is
everywhere do I not fill Heaven and
Earth says the Lord Jeremiah 23 24 so
how are any of us sinners able to
survive in God's presence because we're
always In God's Presence without his
overwhelming Purity uh destroying us
and the answer is this that God
mercifully protects us from the
consequence of sin for a while so that
we have the opportunity to see his love
to see the truth and to make a choice in
Genesis 2 17 God presented the issue
completely clearly to Adam he said if
you eat of the tree of the knowledge of
Good and Evil on the day you eat of it
you shall certainly die or a literal
translation dying you shall die but the
full sentence was delayed so that they
could see we could see the clear issues
that involve the two sides and that
issue is introduced in Genesis 3 21 also
for Adam and his wife the Lord God made
tunics of skin and clothed them this is
a sacrifice and so God was showing them
the other way the message that is given
in the second angel in Revelation 14
says Babylon is Fallen which means the
enemy is already defeated but we just
have not seen the end result of it yet
the enemies will receive judgment
because God cannot let sin continue and
this is how to understand it God cannot
let sin continue without an answer
Rebellion must be dealt with and that
answer is given in Jesus and it was
given before creation through the Lamb
of God slain from the foundation of the
world in Revelation 13 8. and that
answer will not be completely understood
or fully acknowledged until a little
later and at that time then then it will
be fair everybody will see the fairness
and as Philippians 2 verses 10 and 11
says at the name of Jesus every knee
shall bow in heaven and on Earth and
only then when the universe sees and
understands and agrees that God is just
then God will give to Satan in all
Sinners the just result of the choice
that they made
and Satan will be thrown into the lake
fire and destroyed
lights out no more sin forever right
amen
sins cannot exist in the presence of a
holy God okay here we go
this is an interesting question this is
from Instagram okay since we are husband
and wife here we go okay what is the
biblical dynamic between a man and a
woman and between a husband and a wife I
must make it I'm gonna make a shocking
statement it's kind of like Wonder
because you're what I don't I don't
believe in sex between a man and a woman
that may sound strange I believe in sex
between a husband and a wife
I've done that once and I know when the
whole congregation got
you could take a breath now here's what
the Bible teaches as the dynamic and I'm
glad you used the word dynamic between
man and woman and husband and wife
because in our society today the lines
are blurred true they are not blurred
the lines have actually almost been
erased and it's a sad reality today what
I want to say before I make these
statements is I'm speaking about what
the enemy has done to the world and how
people today have to really be mindful
not to allow themselves to go down this
path it's a sad reality let's talk about
God's Dynamic and I'm not speaking about
society's Dynamic but God's Dynamic
Genesis 1 verse 27. and 28. so God
created man in his own image first of
all we have to come to the conclusion
that we are not binaries we are we are
representations of the image of God Amen
this society today said well I feel my I
feel I'm binary I don't I don't I'm not
a particular gender well is is as much
as you want to be it's impossible to
change what God has created and
designated in the image of God he
created him male and female he created
them that's how God designated the role
of man and woman then God blessed them
and God said to them
be fruitful and multiply fill the Earth
and subdue it
have dominion over the fish of the sea
and over the birds of the year and over
every living thing that moves on the
earth so God created man and woman to be
in the dynamic of ruling over all of
creation that's God's Dynamic secondly
God created man to be married to a woman
society today doesn't support that and
it's sad that the church as vocal as it
is and some Churches have even accepted
that as a norm
praise God The Seventh-Day Adventist
Church has not done so although we value
the precious lives of those who have
been LED down the wrong path the Bible
says in Genesis chapter 2 verse 24
therefore a man shall leave his father
and mother and be joined to his wife and
they shall become one flesh when man and
woman are joined together they complete
the image of God in the human race Satan
wants to Mar the image of God so he
unites man with man that's why Paul I
mean Roman I mean Paul says in Romans 1
verse 26 talks about this marring he
says for this reason God gave them up to
vile passions for even the woman
exchange the natural use for what is
against nature likewise also the men
leaving the natural use of the woman
burned in their lust for one another men
with men committing what is shameful and
receiving in themselves the penalty of
their era which was due what's the point
I'm making here
God has a standard that no matter how
much legislation Goes Forth or how many
people change their mind and don't want
to be identified now even on birth
certificates they're saying don't put
mom and dad put person in person well a
person and person can't create a baby
only a woman and a man together
that's the only way God intended and it
cannot be altered no matter how delicate
and how professional a surgeon is you
cannot change the function of the male
body
and you cannot change the function of
the female body remember this what is
highly esteemed among men is abomination
in the sight of God Luke 16 15. if you
want to please God let God's
establishment be the way that you live
and practice for his glory not for the
praise of the world wow well said
do not be conformed that's right but be
transformed by the renewing of your mind
and this world needs their minds renewed
seriously amen oh well thank you I'm
gonna okay if you just joined in and
you'd like to send a question in you can
email us at bibleqa at
3abn.tv I'll say it again Bible QA at
3abn.tv or you can call send a text in
to
618-228-3975 if you have Instagram you
can also send a question in that way
at 3abn underscore official okay thank
you now let's go to Shelley
here's this is from Heather in Canada
why was Aaron not punished by God when
he created the golden calf while Moses
was upon the mountain with God Ah that's
a great question it is there is a
Biblical answer let me kind of set this
up for people who don't know the story
when the Hebrew children were at Mount
Sinai God spoke The Ten Commandments to
them Moses goes up the mountain he gets
the
civil social and ceremonial laws that
are the Constitution from God this is
the Constitution for Israel he comes
down he tells the people they agree
then he writes these words in the book
of the Covenant and we find in Exodus 24
7-8 the people that are into Covenant
with God and because they ratified that
Covenant with the blood so what happens
Moses goes back up the mountain now God
gives him all the instructions to build
a sanctuary and then finally God writes
with his own finger The Ten Commandments
on both sides of the stones Moses is
unaware that the people who had just
ratified the old Covenant with
have already broken it they have created
an idol and I love I think it's so funny
what Aaron says is these people gave me
their goals I threw it in the fire and
this calf came out but they created this
golden cap they're dancing around this
having a pagan party an idolatry that
means they broke the Covenant with god
well Moses is up there God's just
handing him the Ten Commandments and all
of a sudden God's anger erupts and Moses
doesn't know what's going on and God
tells him that these stiff-necked people
have broken the Covenant I mean that was
the end of the Covenant he had to renew
the Covenant later but so what happens
Moses intercedes because God is ready to
wipe the people out their their Covenant
Breakers their Sinners they've rejected
God he's going to reject them so Moses
intercedes it softens God's heart he
agrees not not to destroy the people
Moses returns to Camp he's got the
tablets the Commandments in his hands
and he sees this he drops they shatter
just like the people had already
shattered them he grinds up that stone
throws it in the water and makes them
drink it so that the only thing
remaining of I mean the calf is what he
ground up the only thing that would be
remaining of that Idol was human dung
but he knew that God's anger burned
against Aaron he was painfully aware of
that and we don't find the answer in
Exodus but we do in Deuteronomy 9 19
through 20. Moses says for I was afraid
of the anger and the hot displeasure
with the Lord which the Lord was angry
with you Aaron to destroy you but the
Lord listened to me at that time also
and the Lord was very angry with Aaron
and would have destroyed him so I prayed
for Aaron also at the same time it was
intercessory prayer that saved Aaron wow
amen amen intercessory prayer
that's powerful yep I love this so if
you know someone that in your family or
a special person anyone intercessory
prayers powerful pray for them love that
okay Daniel
this is an email that was sent in can
someone set aside a day for worship
instead of the normal Sabbath and
embrace that day as the official rest
day in accordance with them
the answer to that question according to
the Bible is no it really boils down to
the issue of is God in charge or am I in
charge but there's more to it all right
if I were to tell you that I lived in
the seventh house on the street would
you then go knock on each of the first
seven houses to see which one I lived in
no it's a specific one if I had a date
with my wife of course and I said meet
me at the seventh hour afternoon that'd
be seven o'clock that's a specific time
and I decided to wait for her at one
o'clock or five o'clock she would think
that I stood her up my birthday is in
the seventh month of the year could
someone set aside a different time and
say no this is the time of your birthday
no because that event is tied to
historical event in the past when I was
born in July and so is the Sabbath and
so when we read the fourth Commandment
in Exodus 20 remember the the Sabbath
day to keep it holy and verse 11 then
tells us why four in six days the Lord
your God made the heavens and the earth
and the Sea the Sabbath is a memorial of
a specific event at a specific time in
history and God wants us to remember
that event and what it means to us I
know I already mentioned my birthday but
let's talk about an anniversary could I
just say to my wife this year our
anniversary is on May 12th which is not
our anniversary because I like it better
it's not really a matter of an opinion
or a matter of preference it really is a
matter of love that's what it's about as
the anniversary day approaches both
husband and wife anticipate or should
anticipate with smiles the warmth of the
their relationships celebrating their
commitment and their loyalty and what
they mean to each other and when they
remember that day so long ago keeping it
fresh in their memory it means something
the Sabbath day on the day God has
chosen reminds us that he created us and
that he loves us enough to give his life
for us that's right I cannot simply
identify the Sabbath based upon my will
I simply have the choice to remember the
Sabbath or observe the sabbath but I
cannot change it the Sabbath is based on
three things here it's based on God's
word Psalm 119 verse 89 says forever O
Lord your word is settled in heaven and
it's based on God's character Malachi 3
Verse 6 says for I am the Lord I do not
change and the Sabbath is based upon
God's law of love from his Covenant
Psalm 19 verse 7 says the law of the
Lord is perfect there's nothing about it
that we need to change or should ever
want to change it's a beautiful blessing
as it is wow amen well said yeah it's
God's day he picked that day he chose
that day he rested on what day the
seventh day thank you
okay
here we go John this is from Eustis an
email it says I'm taking care of my
uncle and I don't go to church but
follow on 3abn glad you do
I do not pay tithe in any church is
given to the needy considered a form of
tithing thank you for the question
Eustis you know we have a lot of people
that are in similar situations that for
whatever reason don't attend a church
now some people find a church on the
internet some Adventist Church like ours
we have some people that say I live so
far from a church facing their Church to
Tom they send their tithe to
Thompsonville The Seventh-Day Adventist
Church so that it could follow the
biblical mandate bring you all the tithe
into the storehouse that's something I
would strongly recommend that you
consider doing that now is giving to the
needy considered a form of tithing well
the Bible doesn't talk about it that way
the Bible talks about tithe and
offerings and offerings were used for
outside uh the factors of ministry that
were outside of the tithing system when
you look at the tithing system in the
Bible in Leviticus you see that the
ministers who were ministering of the
Holy Temple were their their livelihood
was furnished through the tithing in the
Adventist Church tithing covers the
salary of the ministers and also our
teachers and other asp affects smaller
aspects of the function of the
Seventh-day Adventist Church but
consider for a moment if the tithing
system would dry up what will happen to
the impact of the ministry if everybody
decided yeah I'm going to give mine I
want to give my money to something else
well the whole structure the storehouse
as it were and everything that is needed
to keep it together would literally
crumble around us but now can we give to
other forms of ministry can we support
people well the Bible says in second
Corinthians 9 6 and 7 those who so
sparingly reap sparingly those who so
bountively reach bound reap bountifully
Let each one gives as he purposes in his
heart but tithing is not as your purpose
in your heart tithing is 10 of your
income which is to be given into the
storehouse there are many Ministries
supported around the world including
through ABN by people such as yourself
that says Hey I want to support that
Ministry I'm going to put aside a
certain amount of offering to send to
them on a monthly basis or maybe once a
year or maybe after I receive my taxes
back or my refund back they may want to
do that but let me strongly recommend
get connected to a church where you can
send your tithing directly to them and
they could then therefore put it into
the storehouse now would God get mad at
you the issue is not whether God gets
mad at you but the issue is whether or
not you want the blessing that follows
that and the Lord says if I will not
open for you the windows of heaven and
pour you out a blessing that there will
not be room enough to receive it Malachi
3 and verse 10.
and finally when you decide to give to
Ministries when you decide to support
other causes whether it is in Africa or
in Asia or in Europe or wherever it may
be in America remember this Luke 6 verse
38 give and it will be given to you give
and it will be given to you good measure
pressed down shaken together and running
over will be put in your bosom for with
the same measure that you use it we will
be measured back to you remember the
cheerfulness of your giving God will
bless you with the cheerfulness of his
giving amen and you as a pastor you've
returned even pastors that are employed
by the church we return tithe on a tie
that is used to even give our salary so
you know it's a it's a cycle that
continues to go forward and believe me
for the existence of the church it has
continued to work because we follow
God's mandate amen beautiful
so good we don't pay tithe we return
there you go thank you yes we return
okay Shelly this is an interesting
question I've never heard this question
before and I looked it up and my husband
helped me he says can you explain the
intertestamental period the the
inter-testamental period boy that's a
big word isn't it the last book of the
Old Testament was written by the prophet
Malachi the first book Matthew is
recording events that happened fourth
Century of the first book of the New
Testament is Matthew recording events
that happen four centuries later so the
inter-testamental period is the 400
years of Silence basically between
Malachi and Matthew God did not have a
prophet who was actively prophesying
during that time it was a time of
Silence now there's so much history to
cover here but do know that during this
time is when the Greeks came up then the
Romans came up and I want to focus on
two
primary things that I think are
important to the religious world that
happened during the 400 years
two sects of the Jewish religion arose
during that inter-testamental period of
time the Pharisees and the Sadducees the
Pharisees controlled the synagogues the
Sadducees controlled the temple services
and operations operations in Jerusalem
and you know what they both taught a
fatally flawed Heir that the coming
Messiah would be a political deliverer
it's not taught anywhere in the Old
Testament but they did teach that but
here's what happened from the time that
God's people went into captivity and
then we see as God prophesied all of
these kingdoms they're unfolding we're
all the way up to Rome what happened is
language influence change a lot of
people who were Jewish no longer spoke
their natural Hebrew tongue they
couldn't read and write Hebrew so During
the intertestamental period the thing I
think is most beautiful in my mind
is about 250 BC there were either 70 or
72 Jewish Scholars got together
and they began well they didn't do it
together they did it separately but they
were commissioned to translate the Old
Testament from Hebrew to Greek why is
that so exciting because every one of
these 70 or 72 Scholars their finished
work is called the Septuagint the
translation of the 70 or you may see lxx
which is the Roman numerals for 70. but
the Septuagint made God's word available
not only to all the Jews who could no
longer speak Greek but to all the Greek
speaking languages and it was very
influential in the New Testament Church
it was the Bible of the New Testament
Church but here I've got to say this in
the Greek there's two words for Covenant
there was syntheke which means contract
deity which means a will and every one
of these 70 Scholars translated everyone
of God's covenants as his will God does
not make covenant contracts with people
oh that's right well said Shelly in that
little bit of time we had wow I got to
go straight to you Daniel okay
my Seventh-day Adventist Church moved
and is now too far away so I don't have
a church to attend
my only other options are Lutheran or
Catholic churches
I do not have internet access
I do have 3abn on my TV
what can I do can I watch the services
on 3abn TV on Sabbath does that count in
God's eyes the Lutheran Church doesn't
have Saturday worship but the Catholic
Church does offer Saturday service Karen
all right Karen Now that statement that
my church has moved would confuse the
minds of people in first century
Christianity how can your church move
your church is people who are committed
to Jesus and work together and uh I
don't know exactly everything about your
situation but God has placed each of us
in a place where we can still Shine the
Light of God's word and we can find a
way to fellowship with believers who
share our faith the Bible is a total
system of Truth not just disconnected
theological ideas a single fabric of
Truth and when we go to a source that
does not accept that fabric of Truth we
open ourselves up to receive things that
are not going to be in line with God's
word and so you may say who am I what
what can I do just one person any one of
us can have a mission where we are I
think of that little made there
ministering to Naaman I think of the
small group of women meeting outside of
Philippi when there was not a church and
I think of churches that met in the
homes there in in the New Testament
Church in our connected age even for
those without an internet connection
there are ways to stay connected I know
that there are phone lines where you can
meet it you can call in and have prayer
groups with people over the phone and
thank goodness for thank God for 3abn
and yes you can join together
fellowshipping with Believers even
though you're not in the same room with
them I know just myself last week I I
met with a group of people 2 000 miles
away and we prayed together and we
studied God's word this was over a video
chat over my phone I know God has made
those options available to us and as you
pray about it God will open up a door
for Ministry for you even though it
might be a small door and a narrow road
it's the one that God has placed you on
right now
thank you well said okay last question
Pastor John if God is real why does he
allow suffering
well God is real that's why he allowed
the suffering of his son I want you to
grab that suffering of humanity is not
the issue it's the suffering of his son
that will one day eradicate the
continued suffering of humanity this is
something that we often think that God
should step in and end suffering nothing
bad should happen to anybody we're
living in an enemy's territory every one
of us have sinned and fallen short of
God's glory none of us has anything
about us that causes God to say you know
I need to save you but it's the love of
God that reached into suffering Humanity
God was willing in the Covenant with
with with salvation to say my son will
suffer that one day there will be no
more sickness No More Death no more
suffering no more crying no more pain
and so Revelation 21 is a declaration
that the suffering we face now is not
permanent it's temporary people die
they've been dying ever since Cain
killed Abe people death has passed upon
all Humanity so let us not allow the
suffering to forget that Jesus himself
suffered that one day throughout
eternity we will never suffer again amen
John 3 16. God so loved the world
beautiful wow and we're in enemy's
territory that's right that's right and
you mentioned that wow well we're going
to have to take a break and we will have
information and how you can send your
questions in to us we will be right back
if you're enjoying our 3abian Bible q a
then tell your friends each Monday will
bring you a fresh program answering the
Bible questions you send us using God's
holy word to shed light on those texts
that seem difficult to understand to
have your questions answered on a future
program just email them to us at bibleqa
at 3abn.tv that's Bible QA at 3abn.tv
you may also text your questions to
618-228-3975 that's
618-228-3975 be sure to include your
name and where you live and then
watch3abian Bible q a for answers from
God's word
we just have a few moments for closing
thoughts so I'm gonna go straight to you
honey yes this whole thing about
suffering it's a sad reality it's the
lot of humanity it is what has happened
to us since the Garden of Eden but
there's some good news you know the good
news is found in Romans 5. it's all
through the Bible the whole Bible is a
love story to us but I love Romans 5
here it says in verse 6 for when we were
still without Strength In Due Time
Christ died for the ungodly you know
when I think about that scarcely for a
righteous man will anyone Dare To Die
perhaps for a good one but God
demonstrated his love towards us in that
while we were yet sinners Christ died
for us now let's see God demonstrate
that through Christ they made a contract
to save us friends suffering is one day
going to be gone that's right thank you
and the courtesy of God's great love for
us and the Willing sacrifice for Jesus
Christ that Covenant of Salvation has
been ratified by his blood and will be
appreciated throughout eternity thank
you thank you my children ask me today
dad what are you answering for Bible q a
and I said well one of the questions is
what's the role of the Holy Spirit and
my 14 year old daughter said that's what
I'm studying right now so I can prepare
a lesson to teach people I was really
excited about that maybe she should be
on this panel but I just mentioned that
to encourage you yourself to study the
Holy Spirit and each of these topics as
God brings them to mind because God has
truths for you to find in his word
I just want you to know that you are
worth nothing less than the price he
paid to redeem you with the precious
lifeblood of Jesus Christ that's in
First Peter 1 18 and 19. oh I was so
blessed today weren't you thank you
thank you each one of you and for those
that are watching God bless you sanctify
them by thy truth Thy word is truth John
17 17.
[Music]
thank you